Traductor: Nerea García Garmendia
Revisor: Larisa Esteche
Quiero contarles, para empezar,
una historia que a mí
como psicólogo me fascina.
En 1972, los ocupantes de la Casa Blanca
estaban preocupados por una invasión
que temían que tuviese lugar
en territorio norteamericano.
No una invasión de comunistas,
como en aquella película
de Chuck Norris de los años 80,
sino una invasión de yonquis.
Y esos yonquis eran los soldados
americanos destinados en Vietnam.
¿Por qué?
Según parece, el consumo de droga
en el ejército americano en Vietnam
alcanzaba unos niveles tan astronómicos
que formaba parte de la vida
y de la cultura de allí,
igual que el rock and roll
o disparar a la gente pobre.
Los soldados americanos,
previos a ser destinados a Vietnam
mostraban un patrón de consumo
prácticamente inexistente:
menos del 1% eran adictos o consumían
habitualmente alguna sustancia.
La mayoría nunca había probado nada.
Pero llegaban a Vietnam y aquello parecía
un poblado de venta de drogas
o un "after" a las cinco de la mañana.
La mitad consumía drogas múltiples veces
a lo largo de su periodo allí,
turnos que muchas veces eran de 13 meses.
1 de cada 5 eran adictos.
Esto generaba una enorme
preocupación en el gobierno,
porque pensaban: "Qué vamos a hacer
con esta gente cuando vuelvan aquí.
Qué vamos a hacer con miles de adictos
a la droga sueltos por nuestras calles
con entrenamiento militar,
incapaces de integrarse en sociedad".
La imagen era prácticamente
un apocalipsis zombie.
Se imaginaban, por ejemplo,
como en la portada de la revista Time,
que los más vulnerables serían los negros,
los pobres, la gente con pocos estudios,
pero esto no era cierto.
El patrón de consumo no dependía
de la raza, la clase social,
ni de ningún factor que pudieran aislar.
Afectaba a todo el mundo por igual.
La gente podía consumir
por estar en combate o no,
podía consumir por haber tenido
una experiencia traumática o no.
Algunos empezaban a consumir
porque en el hospital les administraban
morfina para sus heridas,
pero muchos simplemente consumían
porque lo hacía todo el mundo.
Las explicaciones tradicionales
no parecían dar cuenta de qué pasaba.
Así que se imaginaban bandas
como en las películas...
Se nota que me gustan
las películas de los 80, ¿verdad?
Como en The Warriors, bandas corriendo
por las calles, sembrando el caos,
veteranos peligrosísimos incapaces
de incorporarse a la vida normal...
un desastre.
¿Y qué es lo que pasó?
No pasó nada.
A la vuelta del despliegue de Vietnam,
el 1% de los soldados que consumían drogas
mantuvieron el hábito de consumo.
Esto es el mismo porcentaje que consumía
antes de la guerra, ni más ni menos.
El resto de soldados, en un período
promedio de un año, dejaron de consumir.
Imagínense todos los "cuñados"
de las tertulias televisivas y de radio
completamente desconcertados
después de mucho tiempo preocupándose
y comiéndose la cabeza con esto,
y la cosa era un poco un anticlímax, ¿no?
Ibas a tener un apocalipsis
y no tuviste nada.
(Risas)
Qué corte de rollo.
¿Qué pasó?
Una posible respuesta vino
unos años después, en 1978,
de la mano de un psicólogo
llamado Bruce K. Alexander,
que hizo una serie de experimentos
muy conocidos, como el Rat Park,
el parque de ratas.
En estos experimentos, Alexander utilizaba
un colectivo de ratas Wistar,
que son los mejores amigos del psicólogo
experimental después del perro,
y las separaba en dos grupos.
Uno de los grupos estaba
más o menos en una cárcel,
y el otro en un resort en Punta Cana,
para que nos hagamos una idea.
O sea, el grupo A eran ratas que estaban
en las típicas jaulas de laboratorio,
aisladas y separadas de otras ratas
y con muy poca cosa que hacer
a lo largo del día.
El otro grupo, el del resort,
estaba en el Rat Park,
que era un espacio muy grande
lleno de túneles
y sitios donde las ratas podían jugar,
explorar, interactuar con otras ratas.
Ambos grupos tenían depósitos de agua
con morfina a su disposición
y de agua sin morfina.
Las ratas podían autoadministrarse morfina
siempre que quisieran,
vamos, "party hard" total.
(Risas)
Y Alexander encontró que las ratas
que estaban en la cárcel
se autoadministraban mucho más
frecuentemente la morfina,
y por tanto desarrollaban
más fácilmente hábitos de adicción,
pero que las ratas
que tenían otras cosas que hacer
a menudo evitaban el agua con morfina
y se dedicaban a jugar con otras ratas,
a explorar, a hacer cosas de rata
y a pasárselo bien.
Algunas ratas de este grupo se enganchaban
a la morfina, por supuesto,
pero eran muy pocas.
Esto chocaba frontalmente
con la concepción
de que las drogas
eran adictivas en sí mismas,
porque es la primera prueba
de que quizá el entorno
también tenía algo que ver,
y parece que estos experimentos
eran generalizables a humanos,
viendo cómo se comportaban los soldados
americanos que volvían de Vietnam.
Por supuesto, las drogas tienen
capacidad de causar adicción,
pero no es toda la historia:
el entorno parece tener también un peso.
Esto es, los soldados salían de un entorno
en el que el consumo de drogas era normal,
volvían a sus casas,
muchos de ellos regresaban
con sus familias, sus seres queridos,
encontraban un trabajo,
desarrollaban relaciones sanas
y lo dejaban.
Tan simple como eso.
He empezado con esta historia,
porque como psicólogo,
el si la gente puede cambiar
y cómo cambiamos
es parte esencial de mi trabajo,
de nuestro trabajo.
Los psicólogos somos
modificadores de conducta,
ya sea en la consulta ayudando
a un paciente a superar un problema,
ya sea en una empresa
desarrollando a un equipo
para que adopte
una nueva forma de trabajar,
ya sea en una escuela un orientador,
tratando de que un alumno
adquiera hábitos de estudio.
Lo que hacemos es estudiar
cómo cambiar a la gente
de forma que la gente cambie para mejor
y para conseguir sus objetivos.
Y claro, lo que la gente cree que pasa,
muchas veces no es lo que realmente pasa
cuando hablamos de conducta humana.
La psicología popular tiene poco que ver
con la psicología científica,
y una de las ideas reinas
en lo tocante a la capacidad de cambiar
de los seres humanos
es la idea de que para cambiar
hace falta mucha fuerza de voluntad,
que es la razón o la excusa
por la que te apuntas al gimnasio,
vas dos semanas y luego te pegas
seis meses pagando y no vas nunca,
porque total vas a ir la semana que viene.
Saludo a mi gimnasio, por cierto.
(Risas)
Es la razón por la que empiezas una dieta,
pero en cuanto tienes un mal día
te "entripas" la cara de helado
y de galletas,
y de beber albóndigas.
(Risas)
Es la razón por la que eres estudiante
y estudias el examen el día antes,
todos los cursos te juras
que este no va a ser así,
pero al final siempre acabas cayendo,
porque tienes que salir de farra,
porque no tienes voluntad.
Otra gente sí la tiene,
por eso ellos sí pueden cambiar,
pero tú no, tú no tienes voluntad.
Esa idea, de hecho, ha tenido cierto
predicamento en la psicología.
En los últimos años
se puso bastante en relieve
un modelo desarrollado
por el psicólogo Roy Baumeister,
el "modelo de agotamiento del ego",
"ego depletion" en inglés,
estipula que la voluntad
sería un recurso energético limitado,
como un depósito de gasolina,
que se agota a medida que tomamos
decisiones difíciles, que nos cuestan.
Los hábitos no nos cuestan voluntad;
las decisiones, sí.
Por ejemplo, comerme el brócoli
en vez de comerme un bollo.
A medida que vamos tomando
decisiones difíciles
nos vamos quedando sin voluntad
a lo largo del día,
de forma que finalmente acabamos
cayendo en nuestros viejos hábitos
y cedemos a la tentación.
Por eso muchas infidelidades
ocurren por la noche,
las dietas suelen romperse
por la noche, etc.
(Risas)
El problema es que este modelo...
no aplaudan todavía, que no estoy dando
una excusa para poner los cuernos a nadie.
(Risas y aplausos)
Este modelo está siendo contestado,
porque está teniendo
dificultades para replicar,
no porque no pueda haber
una cierta verdad en esto,
yo creo que hay algo de esto,
sino porque se deja fuera una parte
muy importante, que es el contexto.
Una cosa que los modificadores de conducta
sabemos es que los seres humanos,
como cualquier otro organismo,
reaccionamos principalmente a las señales
que nuestro contexto nos envía,
del mismo modo que, por ejemplo,
cruzamos la calle con el semáforo en verde
o cuando vemos un signo
como este no nos acercamos.
Nos gusta pensar que tenemos
libre albedrío y que tomamos decisiones,
porque nos gusta pensar
que somos seres racionales,
pero como dice Siniestro Total:
somos seres racionales porque
tomamos las raciones en los bares.
(Risas)
O sea que no.
La mayoría de cosas que han hecho hoy
no tienen una pizca
de decisión racional por su parte,
y muchas veces respondemos al entorno
de maneras que están determinadas
por nuestra genética,
nuestra historia de aprendizaje,
nuestras experiencias y hábitos.
Y de eso es de lo que yo
quiero hablar especialmente hoy.
Algunos psicólogos, para explicar
por qué es difícil cambiar,
han concebido una metáfora.
¿Entienden qué es un metáfora?
La conducta no es así,
pero es una forma fácil
de entenderlo, una simplificación.
Conciben a la persona como un jinete hindú
montado en su elefante,
que va por un camino a través de la selva.
El jinete y el elefante
representan a la persona,
y la selva y el camino representan
el entorno en el que esta se mueve.
El jinete, por tanto, representa la parte
que hace planes a largo plazo,
el que hace los propósitos de año nuevo.
El jinete es un motivado.
El elefante es todo lo demás.
El elefante es nuestro gusto
por la gratificación instantánea,
nuestros hábitos, nuestra emocionalidad.
El elefante es el que quiere
comerse el bollo ahora,
aunque el jinete ha decidido que tocaba
comerse un plato de quinoa ecológica
con salmón hervido
de piscifactoría responsable.
(Risas)
El elefante quiere llamar a tu ex
borracho perdido a las dos de la mañana
para decirle que vuelvan.
(Risas)
El elefante es el que sabe
que tiene que estudiar,
pero acaba de salir una temporada
de Juego de tronos
y lo que quiere es sentarse
delante de la tele y vérsela entera.
Al elefante no le gusta mojarse,
ni sudando ni cuando llueve,
por eso si llueve no somos capaces
de ir al gimnasio o a correr,
porque llueve y me gusta más la mantita.
Al elefante le gustan las cosas
a las que está acostumbrado.
Al elefante le gusta hasta tu ex.
(Risas)
Es como si Ortega y Gasset hubiera dicho:
"Yo soy yo y mis circunstancias",
pero disfrazado de indio y montado
en un bicho de cinco toneladas.
Pero el elefante es muy grande
y el jinete muy pequeño,
y si al elefante se le pone en la trompa
tirar en una dirección,
el jinete lo único que puede hacer
es dejarse llevar,
generalmente acabando
en mañanas de resaca y arrepentimiento.
Así es como Jonathan Haidt explica
esta experiencia que todos hemos tenido
de tener perfectamente claro
qué es lo que hay que hacer
y hacer otra cosa.
(Risas)
Así es como se puede explicar, porque
muchas veces nuestros hábitos,
que están gobernados por el entorno
y responden a señales del entorno,
tienen más fuerza
que nuestras intenciones,
que las cosas que intentamos utilizar
como disparadores de la conducta.
El entorno no solo incluye
el entorno físico,
con nuestras señales
de "tira por aquí", "párate aquí";
incluye también el entorno social,
las personas con las que nos relacionamos,
la cultura en la que vivimos.
Si piensan que es poco importante,
escuchen una cosa:
en 2007, un estudio médico
de la Universidad de Harvard
encontró que si uno
de ustedes desarrolla obesidad,
todos sus amigos íntimos multiplican
por tres la posibilidad de ponerse ceporro
y esto no es porque van todos juntos
a un restaurante a "emporcarse", no.
Si vives en San Francisco
y tu amigo en Nueva York
y tienen un contacto frecuente,
tu amigo se pone ceporro igual.
Él te influye, tú le influyes.
El entorno pesa tanto en nosotros
que podemos cambiar nuestros
hábitos alimentarios sin darnos cuenta.
El entorno puede impedirnos actuar
u obligarnos hacer cosas estúpidas,
como dedicarnos a consumir heroína
mientras estamos en la guerra de Vietnam,
porque todo el mundo lo hace.
Hay un experimento clásico
de la Universidad de Columbia
en el que se dice a unos estudiantes
que van a hacer unos cuestionarios.
Los estudiantes pueden estar solos
o en grupos de tres.
Los estudiantes están
rellenando el cuestionario
cuando empieza a ocurrir una emergencia:
por una reja escondida en la pared empieza
a entrar humo a borbotones
hasta llenar la sala.
Si el estudiante está solo,
hay un 75% de posibilidades
de que se levante inmediatamente,
vaya a pedir ayuda y dé la alarma.
Pero cuando el estudiante
está con más gente,
solo el 38% de las veces
se levanta y pide ayuda.
Piensen: el 62% de los estudiantes
se quedaron sentados como capullos,
tragando humo,
porque todos estaban esperando
a que alguien hiciera algo,
y como nadie hacía nada,
todo el mundo se quedaba quieto.
En una situación desconocida,
el contexto nos dice qué hacer,
y si no recibimos señales
del contexto, no hacemos nada,
como ustedes ahora,
que está entrando aquí humo
y están todos callados mirándome.
(Risas)
El contexto determina y el contexto
inhibe nuestras conductas.
También se puede usar para el bien,
de hecho un pequeño cambio contextual
puede provocar
enormes cambios de conducta.
Un ejemplo que me encanta, porque además
tiene una amplia aplicación,
es un experimento en el hospital
Kaiser South en San Francisco,
desarrollado por la jefa
de enfermeras Becky Richards.
Ella quería disminuir los errores
en la administración de medicamentos
por parte de las enfermeras,
porque un error podría ser fatal.
La fuente de estos errores
eran las distracciones de gente
que interrumpía a la enfermera
preguntándole cualquier cosa:
médicos, enfermeras, otros pacientes,
familiares de pacientes,
la tuna que pasaba por allí, quien fuese.
Y decidió usar un simple
cambio en el entorno
para que esas enfermeras
no fueran distraídas,
que fue esto: chalecos reflectantes,
cutres, feos como un cáncer,
de los que se compran en cualquier tienda
para cambiar neumáticos,
y una regla: si llevas el chaleco puesto
es que estás poniendo medicación,
si estás con el chaleco puesto
nadie te puede hablar
y tú no debes contestar a nadie.
Las enfermeras, por supuesto,
lo odiaban con toda su alma,
porque les pareció un castigo, una muestra
de que eran incompetentes en su trabajo.
Sin embargo, a los pocos meses
de iniciar el estudio,
los errores bajaron un 47%,
nadie tuvo que hacer
ningún esfuerzo de voluntad,
ni cambiar nada conscientemente,
solo esa sencilla norma
y ese cambio en el entorno
provocaron un decisivo cambio de conducta.
No siempre podemos cambiar
el entorno para iniciar un hábito,
ni irte de vacaciones a Bora Bora cada vez
que quieres aprender un hábito nuevo,
aunque está comprobado que es más fácil
dejar de fumar en vacaciones que en casa,
porque en vacaciones no tienes las señales
del contexto que te invitan a fumar.
Entonces, ¿qué hacemos cuando
queremos iniciar un hábito?
Un psicólogo de la Universidad
de Nueva York llamado Peter Gollwitzer
desarrolló una técnica llamada
"desencadenantes de la acción",
que es una forma de
anticipar una situación
en la que dispararemos una conducta,
poniendo el control de nuestra conducta
bajo una señal del contexto.
Por ejemplo, si soy estudiante
y puedo hacer un trabajo opcional
para ganar unos puntos extra,
tengo más posibilidades
de hacer el trabajo
en vez de quedarme dormido,
si escribo en un papel:
"Haré el trabajo el sábado tal
a las 9 de la mañana
en el despacho de mi padre
justo antes de que se levanten".
¿Por qué? Porque cuando hacemos eso
predisponemos a nuestro organismo
a reaccionar a la señal del entorno,
de manera que entrar
en ese entorno dispara la conducta.
Esta técnica ha tenido
múltiples aplicaciones
en el ámbito de la salud
y se han obtenido
resultados espectaculares
a la hora de conseguir que, por ejemplo,
pacientes ancianos que han recibido
prótesis de cadera y rodilla
adopten hábitos de salud, de moverse,
en vez de quedarse postrados por el dolor,
acelerando significativamente
sus recuperaciones.
En los hábitos que son difíciles,
que el sujeto percibe
como difíciles de adquirir,
la creación de desencadenantes
de intención multiplica por tres
las posibilidades de éxito:
de un 22% a un 62% en promedio.
En mi propia práctica como psicólogo,
esta técnica se ha probado valiosa,
porque algunas de las tareas terapéuticas
que los pacientes tienen
que hacer son pesadas.
Por ejemplo, en terapia cognitiva
una de las técnicas fundamentales
es llevar un registro de tus pensamientos,
de forma que puedas detectar
los pensamientos disfuncionales
que te causan ansiedad, depresión
y otras emociones negativas,
y sustituirlos
por pensamientos racionales.
La mayoría de la gente
no tiene hábito de llevar un diario,
para la mayoría es difícil
sentarse a escribir.
Cuando yo con mis pacientes acuerdo
unos desencadenantes de la conducta
de cuándo y cómo
van a sentarse a escribir,
aumentan enormemente las probabilidades
de llevar a cabo la tarea,
y por tanto aumentan las probabilidades
de que la terapia sea eficaz.
Así que, en resumen,
las personas podemos cambiar,
lo hacemos constantemente,
pero la mayor parte de las veces,
nuestros cambios pueden producirse
y mantenerse con mucha facilidad
si observamos el entorno,
cómo nos influye y cómo le influimos;
cómo el entorno facilita o dificulta
lo que queremos hacer.
El cambio es perfectamente posible,
pero al contrario de lo que muchos creen,
no tiene absolutamente nada que ver
con la fuerza de voluntad.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)